hier soir quand je suis rentrée au
travail je suis partie du stationnement
qui jauge avancé pour aller à la porte
d'entrée puis j'ai eu vraiment un
sentiment de honte
mélanie perron est infirmière en
obstétrique depuis 13 ans l'hôpital de
joliette
elle ne se reconnaît pas dans la vidéo
qui témoigne des derniers moments de
joyce et jake one mais elle ne fait pas
de déni non plus je réclame le droit de
dire que jamais j'ai été comme ça mais
je me sens quand même honteux c'est
parfait j'ai vu une perte moi qui ai pas
envie que ça change le jeu veut pas le
perdre ce sentiment là parce que ça
voudrait dire laisser tomber abdiqué
puis oublié là j'ai pas envie de ça mais
en même temps c'est un poids qui il faut
porter oui pour certains je pense que
c'est un réveil difficile
mathieu berthy fait partie d'un groupe
de médecine familiale dont la clinique
est située à deux pas de l'hôpital il a
mis sur pied un programme pour offrir
des soins chaque semaine dans la
communauté de manawan
il encaisse l'ombre de choc vécu par les
attikameks mais aussi par la communauté
médicale et il ne faut pas se fermer les
yeux dit-il le drame aurait pu se jouer
n'importe où au québec
je perçois un piège à mettre le focus
uniquement sur l'hôpital de joliette
la commission vient clairement démontré
qu'il existait de la discrimination dans
les soins de santé au québec et ce n'est
pas qu'à joliette
il ya beaucoup d'introspection en ce
moment il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
disent est ce que j'aurais pu faire plus
est-ce que ce racisme bloc que je voyais
au quotidien j'aurais pu penser que ça
aurait pu mener à des choses aussi
épouvantable pour la députée de joliette
véronique hivon une partie de la réponse
passe par là où les manifestations de
racisme nous font honte donc est ce que
les gens les dénonce
je parle des allochtone des non
autochtones est ce qui les dénoncent
aussi fermement qui devrait parce qu'on
essaie de la minimiser
et parce qu'on se dit obama font ça doit
être isolé mais dany perron accepte de
vivre avec cet inconfort mais refuse de
rester mobile je suis allé à la vigile
puis on a discuté avec car le conjoint
de junk qu'on connaît très bien à eux eu
sept enfants
on les connaît le comme infirmière à la
salle d'accouchement ya dix visites
merci à votre équipe pour les bons soins
que vous avez offert à ma conjointe ce
soir le ce qui nous a dit c'est je
constate je vous dis que j'ai encore un
peu d'espoir historien qui nous ont
envoyé comme message
le conjoint de cette femme là qui nous
dit merci ça veut dire qu'ils voient
encore il reconnaît encore qu'il peut y
avoir du boulot
un père faut popur mme soleil ou pas
perdre la chance qui nous donne ici
valérie gamache radio-canada joliette